Speaker 1: So Donald Trump was interviewed about
his book, If You Can Believe It. The interviewer
is Fox News's Mark Levin. The main question
should be, Sir, why is this a picture book?
Most presidents write a real book. Why did you
decide to do a picture book now? The reality is,
if Trump wrote a book, it would be very obvious
he didn't write it because Trump can't write in
any way that would lead to a book. Trump's
previous books were written by ghostwriters.
Tony Schwartz is one of those ghostwriter as
he's talked about how Trump doesn't read. Trump
doesn't write. It's all humiliating. Pathetic
thing. OK, so Trump's interviewed about the book
the entire interview is a humiliating farce.
This is an interview that even for Trump,
even for Trump, is particularly
riddled with lies. So Trump
opens the interview with multiple lies about
gas prices. Let's start there. See, make it
a game. See if you can count the number of lies.
Speaker 2: We weren't leaving $85 billion behind.
We weren't leaving 10 cents behind. I said
every bolt, every screw, every nail comes out
and all of these things. And it was a
beautiful period. I was under assault
like no president has ever been.
Speaker 1: And sorry, this is not
even actually the right clip. Let's start
with the gas price clip. I apologize.
Speaker 2: Gasoline was one point
eighty seven cents. That was a year ago.
And now it's, I guess, just had seven
dollars and fifty cents in California.
The rest to follow when I predicted this.
Speaker 1: OK. So let let go through that
line by. Look at everything, Trump said.
Trump says he predicted this. Listen,
everyone predicted that when demand goes back
up as the pandemic eases, gas prices will go up.
Everybody predicted it. That's not unique. Number
two, Trump says a year ago, gas was a dollar 87.
That's a lie. A year ago, the national average
for gasoline was 220. Now you could say, well,
it was still lower than now. Yeah, but it wasn't
187. It was 220. And then Trump says gas is 750 in
California now. Is it possible that there is a gas
station in California selling super premium for
750? It's possible the gas price in California
officially right now is 338. You don't compare
187 or actually 220 to what you can find for
super premium. At one gas station, we compare
actual official numbers. California gas
is 338. A year ago, it was 220 nationally.
We have to compare it to official numbers.
I'm sorry. California is at 470, and that's
the number that we it's not 750, it's 470. The
official price now nationally is 338. And this
is called cherry picking of data. It's lies
all the way down. He's lying about everything.
OK, then Trump talking about how great a period
it was when he was president. Just everybody was
happy. Russia was happy, everybody was happy.
Speaker 2: So I don't think any president has
ever been under assault like this. And one thing
after another phony impeachments. I call it the
impeachment hoax. No. One, the impeachment
hoax. No, to the the Mueller thing, although
it worked out good, but it took two and a half
years and made it very difficult to deal with.
Speaker 1: Remember, Trump still falsely
claims that the Mueller report exonerated
him on obstruction of justice, which it didn't
do. It's like ancient history at this point,
but just he's still lying about it.
Speaker 2: And countries in particular,
Russia, you know, we could have done some great
things with Russia. Very good for our country,
for our economy. Also good for Russia, but you
couldn't do that because they would have said,
Oh, he loves Russia. These people are sick.
Speaker 1: So Trump continuing to kind of
rewrite history sort of in the same way. He also
and this is one of my favorite things Trump talks
about how much he and North Korean dictator
Kim Jong UN liked each other. Remember this
infamous rally speech where Trump said he wrote
me beautiful letters and then we fell in love?
Trump going back and telling his stories about Kim
Jong UN during this very strange interview that
Speaker 2: in a war, that's the
biggest problem we had. So I became,
you know, we did very well with Kim Jong
UN and we liked each other. Now, remember,
Speaker 1: we liked each other, OK? I mean,
we know Trump is sort of smitten by dictators.
We didn't really do well with Kim Jong UN in
the sense that Kim Jong UN made the same vague
promises to Trump that North Korean
dictators have been making to global leaders
for a very long time. They didn't do any
of the stuff. And in fact, remember that
Trump just walked away from the second meeting
because it was going nowhere. Predictably, so
Trump didn't really do anything with Kim Jong UN.
Speaker 2: The terrible thing to say. We're like,
I'll get criticized. All he likes Kim
Jong UN. Well, that's what we have,
and I did. I get along with him. Great. He got
along with me. Great after a very rough start.
If we remember little Rocket Man and the buttons,
he said, we have a red button and we'll use. I
said, No, our button is bigger than yours and
our button works, and it was nasty. And then all
of a sudden it ended and all of that stuff.
Speaker 1: And what's funny is it ended in
Kim Jong UN didn't do any of the stuff he promised
to do, and Trump just stopped talking about it.
It's actually very funny. Trump wants you to
believe it ended in some kind of geopolitical
success. It ended where Trump just bailed on the
second summit. North Korea didn't stick to any of
the promises, and it was never mentioned again as
a foreign policy goal. OK, then Trump going back
to the lies about the 1918 flu, which he still
calls the 1917 flu and is still confused about
Speaker 2: all over the world. So in 1917, as
you know, we had the Spanish flu, it was called
and it possibly killed as many
as 100 million people. You know,
I don't know if you read the history of the
Spanish flu, but you probably I think you
read about everything that you think. But but it
probably was a thing that was most responsible
for ending World War One. Nobody knows all the
soldiers were sick and many were dying. The
Spanish flu was devastating, and they say up to
100 million people died, and it probably did end
World War One. But a hundred million people? OK.
Speaker 1: Again, you can't even keep up with
the lies. It was the 1918 flu, not 1917. We've
looked up and down. We interviewed a World War,
a Spanish flu historian and said, who told us
there's there's no reason at all. Anyone would
call it the 1917 flu number one. Number two, it
did not end World War one. That is not true. Trump
keeps repeating it. It is not true. Now, Trump
says it might have killed one hundred million
people. The consensus death toll for the Spanish
flu is considered 17 to 50 million. And there
is a sort of it could be as high as 100 million
because we don't have great data from some other
countries. But the important thing is Trump's
trying to use it to minimize COVID. In the U.S.,
the Spanish flu death toll is believed to
be six hundred and seventy five thousand.
We now have almost 800000 deaths from COVID.
So COVID is already more deadly in the U.S.
than the 1918 flu pandemic. It's all lies
all the time. Do you think that the average
Fox viewer realizes the number of lies that
are being told here? I think the answer is no.
Trump then pulls out the communism talking points.
Speaker 2: Number one, I love our country and
our country is based on the Constitution. And,
you know, our country is not living up to the
Constitution right now with the kind of things
you say, it's they're trying to subvert it.
Speaker 1: Now, importantly, when this is, if Mark
Levin was an actual interviewer, he would have
said, Sir, why is your book a picture book? OK, I
already mentioned it. He would have said, Why do
you keep calling it the 1917 flu? Nobody says that
that's the right name for it. It's the 1918 flu.
Why are you lying about gas prices? That's not
true. But when the Constitution stuff comes up,
a real interviewer would say exactly which
aspect of the Constitution or Bill of Rights.
Are they subverting and who is they?
Tell me exactly. It's not asked. And
Mark Levin, who claims to be an expert on the
Constitution, just allows it to have to happen
Speaker 2: and more so now than anybody would
ever believe. Bernie Sanders is saying, I can't
believe they're doing this. This is far more than
what they are doing to our country is perhaps,
you know, they talk socialism. This is communism.
Speaker 1: And now it's not communism. There's
no communism here. There's been no
government takeover of businesses,
and there's just not communism here.
Speaker 2: In many ways, there's no freedom
of the press. The press is totally corrupt. The
press and them are the same. There's no freedom
of the press. That's how communism starts now.
Speaker 1: Those are literally all lies.
And Mark Levin does nothing to push back against
it. Trump then tries to say he did a really
great job on COVID. Really, really good job.
Speaker 2: But I built him a hospital. I sent in
the hospital ship. I built hospitals in Louisiana.
I built hospitals all over, all over portable
hospitals, thousands of beds. We did a phenomenal
job except when it came to public relations,
because no matter what we did, the press would
not cover it fairly. So we did a fantastic job.
Speaker 1: Yeah. We now know that thanks
to Trump's inaction and delayed response
and for months not talking about masks
and saying 15 cases would soon go to zero.
Those decisions, people were going to die. People
were going to die. There's no doubt about it.
But tens of thousands of needless deaths simply
from Trump's slow action. OK. Wrapping this up,
Trump actually talking about the book and
he talks about, you know, his picture book.
It's just humiliating.
Speaker 3: Anyway, yeah,
at a meeting. So with individuals?
Speaker 2: What was that all about? Well,
I have a number of pictures and I have a picture
of Nancy Pelosi. I have a picture of of Merkel.
Speaker 1: And I mean, guys that
this is the most childish thing.
Most presidents write a book. Trump is talking
about the pictures that he put in the book.
Speaker 2: I got along with very
well. That was a point. Also,
we have a lot of pointers. You know, there
are a lot of people pointing, but with Pelosi.
Speaker 1: Okay. So there it is. And then
lastly, lastly, here is Trump saying something
unintelligible about gasoline once again?
Speaker 2: I don't think people see it that
way. They knew that they got gasoline for
x dollars a tank, and now they can multiply
times four. And they're saying, What's happened?
Speaker 1: OK? And of course, gasoline prices
have not multiplied themselves by four.
And Trump telling lie after lie. So the
missing question really is why did you write a
picture book? Most presidents choose to write
actual, you know, they write, you chose
a picture book. That's interesting,
sir. Tell us why that question not asked and
a completely bizarre, humiliating interview
with the former president. We're going
to take a quick break. Make sure you're
following us on Instagram at David Pakman
show, and we'll have much more coming up.